tu
souris tu dois faire
attention je pense qu'ils veulent qu'on vienne les
trouver
ce sont
des images de fouilles archéologiques partout sur
la Terre des civilisations anciennes qui
n'ont partagé aucun contact les unes avec les
autres et pourtant le même pictogramme pour
chacune des peintures rupestres aztèques mésopotamiennes
de
La France c'est une
carte des étoiles non pas une carte une
invitation
Prometheus a
NY jusqu'où iriez-vous pour obtenir vos
réponses que seriez-vous prêt à
faire Prometheus, voyez-vous
ça, qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient raison,
qu'est-ce qu'elle a eu une épingle, qu'est-ce que  tu
vas choisir en un clic où vont
ces choses qui bougent oh mon Dieu ce truc
c'est que nous devons monter maintenant de l'
intérieur qu'est-ce qui se passe là-bas tue
tout est-ce que tu
me copie si tu ne l'arrêtes pas c'est gagné  ce ne sera pas ta
maison où retourner